i had this thought the other day because
i was like on on the topic of celebrity
culture i was like do you think there's
going to be someone who is going to be
as famous as michael jackson is in our
lifetime again
because i feel like probably
you think so probably i don't know i
don't think that who do you think is the
most famous person right now
kim kardashian unfortunately
you know i actually googled this after i
had this thought do you know who was
ranked as num the number one most famous
celebrity well let's see
wait wasn't it like isn't it like
[ __ ] whole it's a footballer probably
right no really
uh cristiano ronaldo leo no messi we're
in the top 10 though what what what's
the occupation actor an actor yeah i was
surprised
i don't know what
number two was donald trump which was
not surprising right right now i think
about it but number one really surprised
me male female male male male actor hold
on i can think
yeah i didn't i didn't intend this to
listen to it
no it is dwayne the rock joke oh yeah
okay
[Music]
and i'm just like is he that famous no
he is he is he yeah like internationally
yeah isn't he like one of the most like
highest paid actors cause yeah he is
like fast and furious movies are like
everywhere yeah everywhere he's also
he's also one of those actors that
looks and feels natural in like an adult
film like fast and furious but also in
like a disney film
yeah you know it's fast and fear isn't
an adult film well i mean compared to
like moana
it's not it's not a kid's movie
you know i mean say what you will but
like having a recognizable face and
figure is like yeah definitely a part of
it yeah that's true yeah and just his
name's the rock you know yeah i mean
people are going to remember that
what surprised me is that he wasn't like
he wasn't the first person to come up to
mind when when i think of like a famous
person right yeah um but he is just
he's also one of those guys where you if
you say the name then you're like oh
yeah of course yeah yeah you know like
yeah he's famous it's definitely easier
when you're when you have like a name
that's super easy too yeah that's true
yeah dwayne the wrong job is also a cool
name right
it's called the pain
it's it's it's more like catchy than
just dwayne johnson yeah because like
especially like traveling around the
world now you realize that people are
just like
people like there's different levels of
famous depending on where you are in the
world yeah cristiano ronaldo is like
known everywhere yeah yeah exactly
football is massive except for probably
like the us right that's probably like
the biggest place they all probably know
right now they're still right maybe do
they do they i don't know i don't know
americans do you know who cristiano are
now doing
i know at one point david beckham was
like the most like the famous person on
earth yeah yeah i don't think he's now
because he hasn't really yeah yeah but i
swear like 10 20 years ago he was like
yeah the most famous person oh yeah yeah
because then they're like beckham phase
well it's it's it's weird to see how
celebrity culture has evolved right
because i'm like how i got onto this
thought was i remember i got recommended
a clip of a michael jackson concert and
it was just literally like michael
jackson's standing up on the stage
standing still and then people are just
like passing out in the crowd
it's it's it's insane
so there's this concert there's a really
famous concert it's on youtube right the
opening right yeah
the lights come on and then from from
the stage there's like a trap door that
opens yeah and michael jackson literally
shoots just like like he emerges out
with some sunglasses and he's standing
there and i swear for 10 minutes this
crowd is losing their [ __ ] there are
people like he literally just stands
there he like he's like the literal clip
on youtube is called michael jackson
stand still and people pass out
he's not even moving
like it's [ __ ] insane and it's just
like insane to think that like he was
like back in the day he was put up to
like almost god-like status i mean i
can't imagine
someone today having that kind of
reaction or anyone today having that
kind of i mean i i feel that way as well
whenever i look at you know like
beatlemania clips from like the 70s yeah
yeah
right people losing their mind to the
beatles all right that's bts now right
you think sorry i don't think i don't
think it's to the same level
yeah i think the thing is with
i don't know i think i think bts is in
like bts fans are like oh challenge
accepted
i mean it's it's the i think it's the
closest thing we've had to that level of
like intensity true but i don't think
we've had anything i think though the
thing is it doesn't look as intense
because a lot of that is all online now
that's true whereas back in the during
beatlemania like if you wanted to go see
the beatles you had to go physically to
go see them that's true i think another
thing is that you just know way more
about the celebrity nowadays because of
social media and it's like it kind of
like humanizes them more than before
when your only exposure to them was
through
was through like
like news media and tv and like
interviews and stuff like that and that
was the only slice you got behind what
was what their lives were and now every
you know about everything like you know
the good and the bad